i've got to say i've met your parents
they as you mentioned they came to the
show
they they couldn't be nicer they seemed
like very laid back
chill people they watched you do your
set uh on my show
which is always very funny but also uh
you know it's it's something i wouldn't
imagine most people would want their
parents around while they're doing their
set and then i saw your parents
afterwards they're like wasn't she
terrific and they're just
you know the most normal people in the
world they're great
but are they laid back are they pretty
chill is it i mean
they're they're okay having you around
obviously they must love it
they they love it we're having a great
time i really am like so grateful that
they are
healthy and i get to have this time with
them um
and and it's it's interesting they're
they're cool i have cool parents
um also known as alcoholics but they
[Laughter]
no i don't i don't uh joke about their
drinking anymore because they actually
quit
uh talking to me and so they don't like
when i do that
but no they're super fun they're so cool
they um
we we we just we're having a great time
we're watching
we watch you every night it's like part
of our ritual i mean like we're big
conan fans in this house i'm literally
sipping from
this right now that's nice yeah i have
i mean i maybe i can't even show this
because you guys don't own the rights
anymore but i have my old tattered copy
of in the year 2000
that is literally was in my nightstand
in my my childhood bedroom that i've
notes in this was my original comedy
notebook so nice
that's great it's uh it looks like it's
been through a lot
you know it has been through a lot of so
is you
yeah that's true that's true it's
actually looking better than i am